مصادر امنيه عراقيه ان هجوما بثمانيه
صواريخ استهدف قاعده لكان العسكريه
التركيه شمال شرق مدينه الموصل مركز
محافظه نينوى دون تسجيل خسائر بشريه
واعلن فصيل مسلح غير معروف يدعى فصيله
احرار العراق
مسؤوليته عن استهداف قاعده زي الكان ب 20
صاروخا من طراز اجراد وفق مقال اضاف
الفصيل وانه سيواصل عملياته
وتوسعها ضد ما وصفه بالمحتل في حال لم
ينسحب من الاراضي العراق
انضموا الينا من بغداد مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد ابراهيم وليد تفاصيل اوف عن هذا
الهجوم وعن هذا الفصيل الذي تبناه وان كان
للسلطه او للحكومه العراقيه في بغداد اي
تعليق حتى الان
[موسيقى]
ولا حتى تصريح من الحكومه في بغداد هذا
رسميا لكن رسميا هناك موقف من قوات مكافحه
الارهاب في اقليم كردستان
هذه القوات اصدرت بيانا تحدثت في عن هذا
الهجوم وقالت انه وقع في وقت مبكر من صباح
اليوم وانه تم استخدام ثمانيه صواريخ في
هذه الهجوم قال البيان ان اثنان منها وقع
داخل القاعده والباقيه وقعت في المحيط
القاعده لم يتحدث اي طرف عن حجم الخسائر
التي يمكن ان يكون هذا الهجوم قد تسبب بها
تسبب بها لكن بعض المصادر من داخل محافظه
نينا وتقول انه اصاب
متعاقد عراقي اصابه اصيب بجروح جراء هذا
الهجوم على الاقل هذا حتى اللحظه هذا الذي
توفر من بيانات وتفاصيل حول هذه الهجوم
لكن مره اخرى اقول مريم
لم يظهر من بغداد لم يظهر من بغداد حتى
اللحظه اي موقف هذا الهجوم ليس الاول الذي
تتعرض له هذه القاعده مريم هذه القاعده
كانت قد تعرضت في الفتره الماضيه الى
العديد من الهجمات المسلحه كانت قسم منها
طالب قاعده بشكل مباشر وقسم منها يقع في
محيط القاعده وجاء هذا الهجوم على شاكله
تلك الهجمات التي وقعت في الماضي من هو
الطرف الذي يقف وراء هذا الهجوم هذا هو
السؤال هناك بيان صادر من فصيل مسلح هذا
الفصيل غير معروف
يطلق على نفسه فصيل احرار العراق او لواء
احرار العراق هذا الفصيد يقول انه جزء مما
يسمى المقاومه الاسلاميه وهذه هذا المسمى
تقف خلف هو العديد من الفصال العراقيه
المسلحه هذا الموقف ليس بجديد الذي تحدث
عنه هذا الفصيل في المرات السابقه وفي كل
مره يقع فيها مثل هذا الهجوم تقول بيانات
صادره من بعض الاطراف المسلحه التي تنتمي
لهذه الفصائل لان هذه العمليه ستستمر وهذا
ما تحدث عنه هذا تفاصيل المسلح قال ان
عملياته ستسمر ضد الاتراك الان ينسحبه بل
هو ابعد من ذلك هذه المره عندما قال ان
هذه العمليه ستوسع وستطال مواقع عسكريه
تركيه داخل على اراضي التركيه هذا التطور
جديد هذا التطور له من قبل مريم على ايه
حال الغريب في الامر ان هذا الهجوم جاء
بعد توقف ليس بالقصير يمكن القول انهم منذ
السلامه من رئيس الوزراء العراقي الحالي
محمد شياع السوداني السلطه في اكتوبر حتى
الان لم يقع مثل هذا الهجوم وهناك من يربط
مثل هذه الهجمات بمواقف سياسيه وتقاطعات
سياسيه تقول هذه الاطراف انها ان هذه
الهجمات تستخدم للضغط على رئيس الوزراء من
اجل تحقيق مكاسب معينه هكذا هو طرح لبعض
الاطراف هنا في بغداد على ايه حال هذا
الهجوم هو ياتي في وقت غريب جدا بعد توقف
ليس بالقصير ولا نعرف على وجه الدقه ما هي
الاهداف المتوخات وما هي الاهداف التي
يسعى اليها هذا الطرف المسلح الذي يقف
وراء هذه الهجوم ما هي الاهداف التي يسعى
الى تحقيقها حتى اللحظه هناك من يتحدث على
انه الهجوم كان باكثر من ثمانيه صواريخ
على الاقل انما ذكره البيان الرسمي في
اقليم كردستان كان بثمانيه صواريخ لكن
البيان الذي صدر عن هذا الفصيل المسلحه
ويتحدث عن 20 صاروخا استخدمت في في هذا
الهجوم هناك ايضا بيانات اخرى قالت انه ان
هناك 15 صاروخا استخدمت في هذه الجمله
بعيدا عن كل هذه التفاصيل ما هو مجود
رسميا حتى هذه اللحظه مريم ان الهجوم كان
بثمانيه صواريخ هذا عن الاقل ما نقله ما
نقلته قوات مكافحه اقلام اقليم كردستان
بانتظار ان تعلن بغداد عن الموقف الرسمي
او عن التصريح الرسمي لهذه الهجوم ومن يقف
وراءه وما هي حجم الخسائر التي تسبب بها
هذا الهجوم
من بغداد شكرا جزيلا لك